margarett ologists mythologists hey
Princess Margaret the crown has given us
a whole new appreciation for you as a
member of the royal family we love your
independent streak but we also realize
that the show isn't quite telling the
whole truth about you in fact some
events have been completely inaccurate
the crown gets a lot of things right
about history but showrunners also take
quite a few liberties keep watching for
ten of the biggest mistakes in the crown
on Netflix
Bravo Mommy Dearest well we call the
foods to have my mother jeopardize this
film you know what she's like a lot of
season three focuses on Princess Alice
coming to stay at Buckingham Palace in
real life Prince Philip's mother did
really come to stay with the royal
family when grease became embroiled in
civil unrest but much of their
relationship in the show isn't quite
accurate they were never really
estranged the way the crown suggests it
means you give birth to Mia she was
never a mother in real life he visited
her often and he wasn't against her
coming to stay in London the Profumo
scandal the crown doesn't always portray
Prince Phillip in the most positive
light
in the 1960s the Profumo affair was a
huge scandal in Britain a lot of
officials were found involved in very
inappropriate parties where women were
hired to entertain men did you have
relations with bismuth in season two the
crown suggests that Prince Philip was
involved in this but there's no actual
record that Philip attended any of these
parties there's no crying in royalty a
display of emotion would not just be
considered appropriate it's expected in
the episode a burr fan a mining accident
devastates a British town the Queen
reveals that she has trouble crying in
public as well as feeling strong
emotions in general I dabbed a bone dry
eye and by some miracle no one noticed
but that's not true at all the Queen has
shed real tears in public several times
and unlike the show the tears she cried
in a burr fan were very real dear uncle
Edward Edward abdicated the British
throne because he wanted to marry a
divorced American woman in the crown
he's shown have a very close
relationship with Prince Charles his
great nephew they did exchange letters
late in Edward's life I wanted to thank
you for writing such lovely letters to
David in his final days but they weren't
nearly as close at the show suggests and
Charles certainly doesn't confide in his
great uncle about his feelings for
Camilla they barely knew one another
Camilla controversy Camilla has been the
subject of public scrutiny for years but
the show got some of their facts wrong
Charles didn't get to know Camilla until
after his great uncle passed away so he
couldn't have talked about her in his
letters and while the royal family
didn't approve of Camilla they didn't
conspire to take Charles away from her
she gave me a warning in the show their
interference is a major plot point but
it was cooked up for dramatic effect and
why have we allowed them to do this lost
in space much of season 3 is about
Prince Philip's midlife crisis he did
experience what could have been won
during this time but few details about
those crisis are known you don't raise
your game by talking or thinking you
raise your game through action the show
fills in the blanks with the moon
landing
this makes Philip question his faith and
lost in the universe but he never had
that reaction
he never even met any of the astronauts
in private the other thing they were
just three little men
the Queen's visit before Edward passes
away queen elizabeth goes to visit him
but the show got a lot of that visit
wrong Edward had brought a lot of
embarrassment to the royal family before
his abdication in the crown Elizabeth
decides to spontaneously go visit him in
exile before he passes but in reality it
was all planned
Edward also didn't give her any letters
from Charles to read like the show
suggests John Armstrong the journalist
John Armstrong is a major character in
season 3 he interviews Princess Alice
and writes a great article about the
troubled royal but John Armstrong didn't
exist and Prince Alice never sat down
for a tell-all interview with a
journalist she was an incredibly private
person the show created Armstrong to
give insight into Alice as a character
because not a lot is known about her
refusing to kneel one of the most
dramatic scenes in the crown happens in
season 1 Philip doesn't want a kneel in
front of Elizabeth at her coronation as
we before anyone but there's no record
of that happening at all and it's not
very likely that it happened either
Prince Philip grew up as a royal and
knew how things worked and the Greek
royal family took a lot of their
traditions from the British Royals it
made for a spicy episode though Margaret
American trip Princess Margaret is a
favorite on the show and in real life
you all seen something she had a whole
bunch of fans called Margaret ologists
before she ever went to America on the
crown her trip to America is a huge
diplomatic success but that is far from
the truth
most of that didn't happen and her
controversial behavior actually
backfired on her it led to Princess
Margaret being temporarily banned from
the US do you love all the awesome shows
on Netflix like the crown subscribe to
the things for more fun videos about all
your favorite TV shows and if you're
watching on your mobile make sure your
settings are set to allow YouTube
notifications then you'll never miss
another video that's it for the 10
biggest mistakes on the crown what was
your favorite episode of season 3 let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
don't forget to like this video on your
way out we'll see you next time